what's up family my name is nick nice to  meet you nice to meet you bro how are  you doing i'm very well how are you  doing can we take a photo a hundred  percent bro tell them about your project  so project's called ranches  point one floor  uh  blouse if you know blough of course i  know who the [ __ ] do you think you're  talking to bro  here's the reason my stuff sold out so  that about four months ago good for you  double the full price on it we have  about 150 traded we're creating a game  kind of gambling probably not smart for  a 13 year old to make a game like  this i did like a gameplay black market  business for six months what i did is i  bought and sold roblox items roblox  doesn't like when you sell their crap i  got shut down eventually  but you learned yeah flipped my way up  and now i'm here i'm glad you're here  bro you enjoying this yeah goodbye enjoy  yeah  [Music]